>> Tucker: ANYONE WHO THINKS
THIS IS THE LAST GLOBAL PANDEMIC
AMERICA WILL FACE LACKED
SUFFICIENT IMAGINATION.
NO QUESTION THIS WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN IN A WORLD CONNECTED BY
JET TRAVEL, THAT IS GUARANTEED.
AS WE SUFFER TO THIS VIRUS,
MAYBE WE SHOULD LEARN SOMETHING
USEFUL FOR THE NEXT TIME.
GOING FORWARD, OUR LEADERS OUGHT
TO BE CERTAIN WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEDICINE AND TESTS AND HOSPITAL
BEDS AT THE LEAST IN CASE
SOMETHING AWFUL HAPPENS
UNEXPECTEDLY BECAUSE IT WILL.
THERE SHOULD BE A PLAN TO
RESPOND QUICKLY TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC THAT PEOPLE IN CHARGE
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THE OBVIOUS LESSONS FROM THE
EPIDEMIC NOW IN PROGRESS.
THERE IS MORE TO LEARN.
HERE ARE A FEW OTHER THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT.
FIRST, BORDERS MATTER.
TURNS OUT THAT IMMIGRATION IS IN
SOME BOUTIQUE POLITICAL ISSUE
THAT ONLY ACTIVISTS NEED TO CARE
ABOUT.
THE QUESTION OF WHO LIVES IN
YOUR COUNTRY IS THE MOST BASIC
ISSUE THAT ANY NATION FACES
EVERY.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER CORONAVIRUS
SPREAD GLOBALLY, SANE COUNTRY
STARTED TO SECURE THEIR BORDERS,
THEY WANTED TO KNOW WHO’S COMING
IN AND OUT AND WANTED TO CONTROL
IT.
IN ISRAEL, WHERE LEADERS CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THEIR COUNTRY,
BORDER CONTROLS WERE SWIFT AND
HIGHLY AGGRESSIVE.
ISRAELIS DID NOT WANT A SINGLE
PERSON WAS POTENTIALLY INFECTED
TO CROSS INTO ISRAEL AND GOOD
FOR THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY, NOTHING LIKE THAT
COULD EVER HAPPEN HERE IN THE
USP DEMOCRATS WILL DENOUNCE IT
INSTANTLY AS RACIST AND
XENOPHOBIC.
NANCY PELOSI WILL GIVE US A
STERN LECTURE OF HOW IMMORAL
ISRAEL IS.
WE’LL BE WAITING FOR THAT
SPEECH.
PROBABLY FOREVER.
GUN CONTROL TAKES ON NEW
SIGNIFICANCE WHEN THINGS FALL
APART.
IT DOES NOT TAKE MUCH FOR A LOT
IN ORDER TO COLLAPSE,
CIVILIZATION ITSELF CAN
EVAPORATE QUICKLY AND OVER THE
CENTURIES, AND OFTEN HAS.
ON SOME LEVEL, ALL OF US KNOW
THIS.
WE ARE ANIMALS WITH THE
COLLECTIVE MEMORY OF PRIOR CHAOS
EMBEDDED IN OUR GENES.
TIMES LIKE THIS, WE ARE REMINDED
HOW PRECARIOUS ANY SOCIETY IS.
GIVEN THAT, YOU’VE GOT TO WONDER
ABOUT OUR LEADERS’ DEMANDS THAT
WE DISARM.
ANYBODY WHO INCREASES THE THREAT
TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND AT
THE SAME TIME TRIES TO PREVENT
YOU FROM DEFENDING YOURSELF IS
YOUR ENEMY BY DEFINITION.
IT’S SCARY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT’S
HAPPENING NOW AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
AMBITION SALES JUMPED BY
HUNDREDSHUNDREDS OF PERCENTS THI
SPEAKING OF OUR LEADERS, WHO IS
REALLY IN CHARGE OF THIS
COUNTRY?
WE THINK WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
THE PEOPLE ON THE BALLOT AT
ELECTION TIME.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO’S
ACTUALLY IN CONTROL OF ANYTHING,
ASK YOURSELF, WHO CAN MAKE YOU
BEG FOR MERCY?
IF ONE OF YOUR KIDS HAD A BAD
INFECTION, YOU WOULD DO ANYTHING
FOR ANTIBIOTICS.
BUT OUR LEADERS DO NOT CONTROL
THOSE GLOVES
DRUGS.
CHINA DOES.
THE CHINESE MANUFACTURER OR
ENTIRE SUPPLY OF ANTIBIOTICS,
NOT INCLUDING OTHER GOODS YOUR
FAMILY COULD NOT LIVE WITHOUT.
HERE IS THE WORST NEWS, THE
CHINESE HATE US AND HAVE VOWED
TO WITHHOLD LIFE-SAVING MEDICINE
FROM US, OUR MOST POWERFUL ENEMY
IN THE WHAT HOW’S THE POWER OF
LIFE AND DEATH OVER OUR COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD NOT LET A SINGLE DAY
PASS WITHOUT FIXING THIS.
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS, AMERICAN
HOSPITALS WILL LIKELY OVERFLOW
WITH THE DIFFERENTLY ILL.
IT’S POSSIBLE MANY PEOPLE WHO
NEED IMMEDIATE CARE WILL BE
TURNED AWAY TO SUFFER AND DIE.
THAT’S A HORRIFYING PROSPECT.
DOES THIS SEEM LIKE THE RIGHT
TIME TO OPEN UP OUR ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD FOR FREE?
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO SICK PEOPLE
IN AMERICA IF WE DID THAT?
IT SOUNDS LIKE A FORM OF
SABOTAGE.
YET THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT EVERY
DEMOCRAT WHO RAN FOR PRESIDENT
PROPOSED IN PUBLIC.
EVEN NOW, AS WE FACE AN
UNPRECEDENTED STRAIN ON OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THANKS TO
CORONAVIRUS, THEY HAVE NOT
CHANGE THEIR VIEW ON THAT.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
THEY ARE NOT THINKING.
THEY ARE BELIEVING.
BELIEVING FERVENTLY IN THE CULT
OF IDENTITY
IF THERE IS A THREAT TO YOUR
KIDS, YOU DON’T POSIT THINK OF
AN EXCUSE OR PRETEND IT’S NOT
HAPPENING, YOU ACT.
YOU DO WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THEM PERIOD.
IF YOU DIE TRYING, IT’S A LIFE
WELL SPENT.
IF YOU ARE FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN YOUR OWN CHILDREN AND
THE KIDS NEXT DOOR, YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT’S NOT REALLY A
CHOICE.
YOU HAVE ONLY ONE DUTY TO THE
LIVES IN YOUR CARE.
YOUR PEOPLE.
THE ONES WHO DEPEND ON YOU.
IN THE END, THAT’S WHAT IT MEANS
TO LEAD A FAMILY.
MEANS NO LESS TO LEAD A COUNTRY.
INSTEAD OF PROTECTING THE PEOPLE
FOR THIS COUNTRY, MAKING CERTAIN